so you might be wondering why I went off
into permutations and combinations in
the probability playlist and I think
you'll learn in this video so let's say
I want to figure out the probability to
the problem I'm going to flip a coin
eight times and it's a fair coin and I
want to figure out the probability of
getting exactly three out of eight heads
so I say three eight heads but three of
my flips are going to be heads and the
rest are going to be tails so how do I
think about that well let's go back to
one of the early definitions we use for
probability and that says it's the
probability of anything happening is the
probability of the number of equally
probable events in which what we're
saying is true so in which we the number
of events the number of events in which
we get three heads and exactly three
heads we're not saying greater than
three heads so four heads won't count
and two heads won't count five heads
we'll only three heads and then over the
total number of equally probable trials
so total number of total total number
not trials total number of equally
possible outcomes I should be using the
word outcomes so just with the word
outcomes it should be the total number
of outcomes in which what we're saying
happens so we get three heads over the
total of possible outcomes so let's do
the bottom part first let's do the
bottom part first what are the total
possible outcomes if I'm flipping a fair
coin eight times well the first time I
flip it out either get heads or tails so
I get two outcomes and then when I flip
it again I get two more outcomes for the
second one and then you know how many
total outcomes well that's two times two
because I'm going to add two in the
first two in the second flip and then
essentially we multiply two times the
number of flips right so that's five six
seven eight and that equals two to the
eighth so the number of outcomes is just
going to be two to the the total number
of flips and hopefully that makes sense
to you
if not you might want to re-watch some
of the earlier videos but that's the
easy part so there's two to the eighth
possible out
when you flip a fair coin eight times so
how many of those outcomes are going to
result in exactly three heads let's
think of it this way let's let's give a
name to each of our flips let's give a
name to them so let me make a little
column call these the flips this is my
flips column and I could name them
anything I could name him Larry Curly
moe I could name him the and why would
need five more names for them but you
know I could name them the seven dwarves
or the eight dwarves really could I have
eight flips but I could you know I'll
just name the I'll number the flipped
flips one two three four five six seven
eight and I'm the god of probability and
essentially I need to just pick three of
these flips that are going to result in
heads so another way to think about it
is these could be eight people and I you
know I could pick which of these you
know how many ways can I pick three of
these people to put into the car or how
many ways can I pick three of these
people to sit in chairs and it doesn't
matter the order that I picked them in
right it doesn't matter if I say the
people that are going to get in the car
are going to be people 1 2 & 3 or if I
say 3 2 & 1 or if I say 2 3 & 1 those
are all the same combination right so
similarly if I'm just picking flips and
I have to say okay three of these flips
are going to be are going to get into
the heads car or we're going to sit on
you know heads is like they're sitting
there people sitting down I don't want
to confuse you too much but essentially
I'm just going to choose three things
out of the eight so I'm essentially just
saying how many combinations can I get
where I pick three out of these eight
and so that should immediately ring a
bell that that we're essentially saying
out of eight things eight we're going to
choose three and that's our that's you
know how many how many combinations of
three can we pick of eight and that's we
went over in the last video and let's do
it with the formula first so let me
write the formula up here just so you
remember it but I also want to give you
the intuition again for the formula
so in general we said n choose K that is
equal to
n factorial over K factorial times n
minus K factorial so in this situation
it would be that would equal 8 factorial
over 3 factorial times what 8 minus K
times 5 factorial or another way of
writing this this would be 8 times 7
times 6 times 5 times 4 times 3 times 2
times 1 over I'll just write 3 factorial
for a second then times 5 times 4 times
3 times 2 times 1 and of course that and
that cancel out and all you're left with
is 8 times 7 times 6 over 3 factorial
and I did this for a reason because I
want you to to reget the intuition for
at least for this part of the formula
that's it just essentially just saying
how many permutations can I you know how
many ways can I pick three things out of
eight and that's essentially saying well
before I pick anything I can pick one of
eight then I have seven left to pick
from for the you know second spot and
then I have six left to pick for the
third spot right and so that's
essentially the number of permutations
but since we don't care you know if we
picked it what order we pick them in we
need to divide by the number of ways we
can rearrange three things and that's
where the 3 factorial comes from and so
we're just hopefully I didn't confuse
you but you know if I did you can go
back to this formula for the binomial
coefficient but it's good to have the
intuition and then well once we're at
this point we can just calculate this
well what's this this is 8 times 7 times
6 over 3 factorial is 3 times 2 times 1
so that's 6 so 6 cancels out so it's 8
times 7 so there's 8 times 7 or what is
that 50 56 right for 56 yeah that's
equal to 56 so there's 56 different ways
to pick 3 things out of 8 or if I have 8
people there's 56 ways of picking 3
people to sit in the car or you know
however you want to view it but if I
have 8 flips there's 56 ways of picking
3
of those flips to be heads so let's go
to our original probability problem what
is the probability that I get three out
of eight heads well it's the probability
it's the number of ways I can pick three
out of those eight so it equals 56 over
the total number of outcomes right the
total number of outcomes is two to the
eighth another way I could write that 56
let me unseparated sate times 7 8 times
7 over 2 to the eighth eighth is 2 to
the third right let me let me erase some
of this not with that color let me erase
that erase all of this so I have space I
will switch colors for variety use the
small pen ok so I'm back alright so 8 is
the same thing as 2 to the 3rd times 7
this is all just mathematical
simplification but it's useful over to
the 8th and so if we just divide both
sides put the top then we're in the
denominator by 2 to the 3rd this becomes
1 this becomes 2 to the 5th and so it
becomes 7 over 32 is that right so it's
the if I were to pick 3 out of 8 yep I
think that is right and and so what does
that turn out to let me get my
calculator I have to make careless
mistakes let's see my calculator seems
to have disappeared
let me get it back there it is ok 7
divided by 32 is equal to 0.2 1 875
equals 0.2 1 8 7 5 which is equal to 21
21 point you know if I were to round
roughly twenty one point nine percent
chance so there's a little bit better
than one in five chance that I get
exactly three out of the eight flips as
heads
hopefully I didn't confuse you and now
you know you can apply that top pretty
much anything you could say well what is
the probability of getting if I flip a
fair coin of getting exactly seven out
of eight heads or you can say what's the
probability of getting you know two out
of 100 heads and you could you could you
know use the exact same way we did this
problem I'll see in the next video